Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 19, Basic. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everyone. So I just got back from Tahoe. For people who know Lake Tahoe is a lake that sits on the border of California and Nevada. And is that right? I think so, yes.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 19 期，基础篇。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。我刚从太浩湖回来。大家都知道，太浩湖位于加利福尼亚州和内华达州的边界。是这样吗？我想是的，没错。
I've done a lot of driving. But basically it's pretty fun. They have like a, you know, you can go skiing in winter. In the summer you can go hiking and rafting and things like that. And so we went rafting. We actually saw a black bear that like literally jumped in the water and started coming towards the raft. And we started freaking out. But he didn't make it all the way to the raft. So he got about like 10 feet away.
我开了很长时间的车。但总的来说还是挺有趣的。你知道，冬天可以在那里滑雪。夏天可以去徒步旅行、漂流之类的。所以我们去漂流了。我们竟然看到了一只黑熊，它真的跳进了水里，开始朝我们的木筏游过来。我们当时都吓坏了。但它没能游到木筏边。它游到离我们大约 10 英尺远的地方。
And then he turned around and ran back. Lucky for all the way to the raft. So he got about like 10 feet away and then he turned around and ran back. Lucky for all the inhabitants of the raft, I guess. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, we were wondering who we should feed the bear. Well, the thing is you don't have to be able to outrun the bear, just the slowest person. What happens if you're in a raft, though? If you're in a raft, you just have to be able to throw one person into the bear.
然后它就转身跑回去了。幸运的是，对于木筏上的所有人来说，我想是这样。是的，没错。我们当时还在想应该把谁喂给熊吃。嗯，问题是你不需要跑得比熊快，只要比最慢的那个人快就行了。但如果你在木筏上怎么办？如果你在木筏上，你只需要能把一个人扔给熊就行了。
You have to be the most liked, the most disliked person.ed person it's a huge disadvantage you have time to take a vote yeah you could pretty much vote someone i think it just makes whoever's the strongest right just throw throw the weakest person off maybe but you can maybe be clever about it like hey get the camera and then push them in or something you know when they're not looking so there's all there's there's opportunity to be crafty here and save yourself you know as in many many dangerous situations in life oh man this conversation's not going anywhere good so bears and rafting so we saw your death experiences okay so so first the bear jumps this is why i don't go outside oh yeah stay inside look at these things on youtube sometimes bears can come inside though you have to be careful i locked my brush so um so yeah so the bear jumps out from the bushes like straight out
你得是那个最受欢迎或者最不受欢迎的人。这可是个巨大的劣势，你有时间投票。是的，你几乎可以投票选出某个人。我觉得这只会让最强壮的那个人获胜，直接把最弱的人扔下去。也许你可以耍点小聪明，比如“嘿，快看那个”，然后趁他们不注意把他们推下去。所以，这里有很多耍花招的机会来拯救你自己，就像生活中许多危险的情况一样。天哪，这段对话可没往好方向发展。所以，关于熊和漂流，我们看到了你们的死亡经历。好吧，首先是熊跳出来，这就是我为什么不出门的原因。哦，是的，待在室内。有时候熊也会闯进室内，你得小心。我锁好了我的灌木丛，所以……是的，熊直接从灌木丛里跳了出来。
of duck hunt or something like bear hunt that was that was a dog the dog comes out of yeah yeah you're right in the ducks yeah yeah so straight out of bear hunt the duck hunt hack i don't know so so then so we're on the raft and go a couple more miles and then take a guess what jumps come flying out of the forest and and jumps in the river a salmon a car like and and it really isn't funny but but no one was hurt so i guess it is funny but seriously a car just like goes right veering off the road and just crashes like into the bank of the river like while we're on the raft um so were you in a monty python real life experience like who is this so so windshields like totally smashed but the people were okay were they in the car when it went i mean there was a driver in the car and
就像《打鸭子》或者什么《打熊》游戏一样。那是狗，狗从……是的，你说得对，是打鸭子。所以就像《打熊》游戏一样，我不知道。然后我们在木筏上又漂了几英里，你猜怎么着？什么东西从森林里飞出来，跳进了河里？一条鲑鱼？一辆车！这真的不好笑，但幸好没人受伤，所以我想这还是挺好笑的。但说真的，一辆车直接偏离了道路，撞进了河岸，当时我们就在木筏上。所以你们是在经历现实版的《蒙提·派森》吗？这是谁啊？挡风玻璃完全碎了，但车里的人没事。他们车掉下去的时候人在里面吗？我是说车里有个司机，
they got out and so it was pretty intense uh and then i'm never going anywhere at these places when you're around because apparently I've been rafting twice and the time before a tree a gigantic sequoia tree almost crushed us so I think we're never going to go rafting again it's two for two crazy things stay away from me you want to go rafting?
他们出来了，所以当时情况非常紧张。我再也不会去这些地方了，只要你在场。因为显然我漂流过两次，上一次是一棵巨大的红杉树差点把我们压扁。所以我想我们再也不会去漂流了。两次漂流都遇到了疯狂的事情，离我远点。你想去漂流吗？
no unless it's on the Wii that's right you can go rafting? No. Unless it's on the Wii. That's right. You can go rafting on the Wii U, which is coming out in a couple of months. Oh, I didn't even realize I was segwaying. So what's different about the Wii U? So I haven't read too much about it, but I am posting this article.
不，除非是在 Wii 上。没错，你可以去漂流？不。除非是在 Wii 上。没错。你可以在几个月后发售的 Wii U 上玩漂流。哦，我都没意识到我在转换话题。那么 Wii U 有什么不同呢？我还没读太多关于它的资料，但我正在发布这篇文章。
And basically, from what I've read, the controllers have a touchscreen on them. And so this, did you ever use that thing where you could hook up your Game Boy Advance to the GameCube? Did you ever do that? And they had like Zelda Four Swords and some other games? Oh, okay. So this was totally awesome. This was way ahead of its time because nobody has four has four game boy advances right so the idea is like you could play this game called zelda four swords and you would use your game boy advance as connected to the gamecube and on your screen you would have private information like the map which you're
基本上，据我所知，它的控制器上有一个触摸屏。你有没有用过那种可以把 Game Boy Advance 连接到 GameCube 的东西？你用过吗？他们有《塞尔达传说：四支剑》和其他一些游戏。哦，好的。那真是太棒了。这在当时非常超前，因为没人有四个 Game Boy Advance。所以这个想法是，你可以玩这个叫《塞尔达传说：四支剑》的游戏，你可以把 Game Boy Advance 连接到 GameCube 上，在你的屏幕上会有私人信息，比如地图，
revealing but but you don't want other people to see and so as you explore the map like as your zelda character explores the map you start to understand where the switches are and how to get past the door and stuff but you don't want to give that information out because you want to be the first one to the finish so that game was totally awesome loved it the Wii U is going to come out with games like that they've already announced they're gonna make a Zelda pretty much like a four swords kind of kind of game so really looking forward to it you're gonna buy one awesome so you know i'm gonna do what i did with the wii where i'm not
你正在揭示它，但你不想让别人看到。所以当你探索地图时，比如你的塞尔达角色探索地图时，你开始了解开关在哪里，如何通过门之类的，但你不想把这些信息泄露出去，因为你想成为第一个到达终点的人。所以那个游戏真是太棒了，我很喜欢。Wii U 将会推出类似的游戏，他们已经宣布要制作一款《塞尔达传说》，基本上就是《四支剑》那种类型的游戏，所以我非常期待。你会买一个吗？太棒了。你知道，我会像对待 Wii 那样，我不会
going to be lining up at the door like killing myself you know to get one but you know after like the hype has died down maybe like six to eight months the controllers come down in price uh yeah i'll probably get one what about you no? No. You're not going to get one? No. I mean, maybe when it goes to $49.99 or $100 or something. How much is it right now? It looks like $300. $300? That was what I just saw.
在门口排队，把自己累死为了买一个。但你知道，等热度消退后，大概六到八个月，控制器价格降下来之后，嗯，我可能会买一个。你呢？不？不。你不打算买一个吗？不。我是说，也许等它降到 49.99 美元或 100 美元左右的时候吧。它现在多少钱？看起来是 300 美元。300 美元？我刚才看到的就是这个价格。
Oh, okay. So, yeah, I mean, what I want is to be able to do that, but with my phone. Yeah, totally. So, like, I have a phone. I have tablets. Probably too many. And everybody I know has them as well why can't i do it with that yeah exactly yeah i feel like connect over bluetooth or wi-fi or whatever and i feel like that would be super awesome yeah i mean i'd give my right arm for just like something that would like hold my phone like have a little cradle
哦，好的。所以，我是说，我想要的是能够做到这一点，但用我的手机。是的，完全同意。所以，我有手机。我有平板电脑。可能太多了。我认识的每个人也都有。为什么我不能用那个呢？是的，完全正确。我觉得通过蓝牙或 Wi-Fi 连接，那会非常棒。是的，我是说，我愿意付出一切来换取一个能固定我手机的东西，比如一个小支架，
for the phone but it would be a gamepad. They have those. Oh, really? Yeah, I think they're iPhones, I think. Oh, man, where can I get my right arm? Uh-oh. They have, yeah. Well, they even have the retro arcade cabinet thing you can put your iPad in.
给手机用的，但它是一个游戏手柄。他们有那种东西。哦，真的吗？是的，我想是给 iPhone 用的。天哪，我能去哪儿弄到我的右手？哦哦。他们有，是的。好吧，他们甚至有那种你可以把 iPad 放进去的复古街机柜。
Oh, I've seen that. And it has, like, a joystick and the actual mechanical buttons. Yeah, that was pretty awesome. And I think it connects over Bluetooth. Oh, okay. So it's actually, so, I mean, I'm sure they have a gamepad or something like that. And I think it connects over Bluetooth. Oh, okay. So it's actually, so I mean, I'm sure they have a game pad or something like that.
哦，我见过那个。它有操纵杆和真正的机械按钮。是的，那真是太棒了。而且我想它是通过蓝牙连接的。哦，好的。所以它实际上是……我是说，我肯定他们有游戏手柄之类的东西。而且我想它是通过蓝牙连接的。哦，好的。所以它实际上是……我是说，我肯定他们有游戏手柄之类的东西。
I think I've seen them before. Yeah, it just, it has to be small form factor. That's the key. Or it has to like fold in on itself. So like you can put it in your pocket. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I mean,
我想我以前见过。是的，它必须是小尺寸的。这是关键。或者它必须能折叠起来。这样你就可以把它放进兜里。是的，完全正确。是的，我是说，
I think there's going to be some really cool things coming out for gaming, but I find myself just playing a lot more casual games than sitting down and playing it. Just I guess where I am in my life, maybe,'t know i've been playing the sims free version on the android phone and uh it's pretty wild so so this this sims you can't speed up time and everything
我觉得游戏领域会有一些非常酷的东西出现，但我发现自己玩休闲游戏的时间比坐下来玩游戏的时间多得多。我想这可能是我现在的生活状态吧。我不知道，我一直在安卓手机上玩《模拟人生》免费版，这太疯狂了。所以这个《模拟人生》，你不能加速时间，一切
takes real time so it is kind of like farmville it's's true. But, you know. You have been hacked, sir. You have been exploited. Prepare for your wallet to drain. Yeah, and it's constantly like, you know. Because you can speed up time if you have money. Yeah, that's right. If you have money, you do it. I knew there was a trick to this.
都按现实时间进行，所以它有点像《农场小镇》。确实。但是，你知道。你被黑了，先生。你被利用了。准备好让你的钱包缩水吧。是的，而且它总是……你知道。因为如果你有钱，你就可以加速时间。是的，没错。如果你有钱，你就这么做。我就知道这其中有猫腻。
Yeah, of course. So, like, I put all the Sims to bed at night, like right when I'm going to go to bed. And so there's something kind of creepy but cool about that. But then it's like, hey, you know, your Sims could stay up all night, you know, gaining experience if you paid like, you know, a dollar or something. To Chinese workers who farm them for you all night? That wasn't, I'm leading into the next story. I wasn't actually trying to be mean to Chinese people.
是的，当然。所以，我会在晚上睡觉前把所有的模拟市民都送上床。这有点诡异但又很酷。但后来它会说，嘿，你知道，如果你付一美元左右，你的模拟市民就可以通宵不睡，获得经验值。给那些整晚为你耕作的中国工人吗？我不是那个意思，我是在引出下一个故事。我并不是真的想对中国人民刻薄。
No, that's true. Chinese workers do a lot of, provide a lot of valuable service to us. You recently learned about that? Yeah, and there's an amazing tech talk. You guys should totally check it out. I'm going to have a link to it. And the tech talk title is The Voice of China's Workers. And just supremely interesting story.
不，那是真的。中国工人确实为我们提供了很多有价值的服务。你最近才了解到这一点？是的，有一个很棒的 TED 演讲。你们一定要去看看。我会放一个链接。那个 TED 演讲的标题是《中国工人的声音》。这是一个极其有趣的故事。
I'll just cover some of the most interesting parts. One is all of them walk around. Like all of the walk around like all the workers they go home with to visit their families and stuff and they bring with them like ipads and coach purses and stuff like that and like designer coach purses because they since they work in the factory they get these at like ridiculous prices so like this lady she's the ones with little blemishes or just like? Well, possibly. It wasn't said. But, yeah, this reporter was like she had followed like several of these women who worked in a coach purse factory.
我只讲其中最有趣的部分。一个是他们所有人都四处走动。所有的工人都回家探亲，他们带着 iPad 和 Coach 钱包之类的东西，还有名牌 Coach 钱包，因为他们在工厂工作，所以能以极低的价格买到这些东西。所以这位女士，她是那些有小瑕疵的，还是……？嗯，有可能。演讲里没说。但是，是的，这位记者跟随了几个在 Coach 钱包工厂工作的女性。
And, yeah, after six months, they gave her like just 20 or 30 coach purses and some other stuff. And she's like, you know, no, give this money to your family. And they're like, what are you talking about like this is like 13 cents or something to us you know and there's like 100x markup that same coach purse sold for like 1200 or something and so just and they actually you know they're not oblivious they know how much the things are sold for in america but they can't like there's no way for them to be able to sell them there yeah exactly and so they walk around saying like this coach purse sells for six thousand like it's like the equivalent of like leaving the price tag on yeah yeah exactly they leave the american price tag on like the purse the purse and stuff but they couldn't sell it for a dollar i guess it's always the interesting thing right people talk about that we put so much
是的，六个月后，她们给了她 20 或 30 个 Coach 钱包和其他一些东西。她说，你知道，不，把这些钱给你的家人。她们说，你在说什么，这对我们来说只值 13 美分左右。你知道，同样的 Coach 钱包在外面卖 1200 美元左右，有 100 倍的溢价。她们其实并不傻，她们知道这些东西在美国卖多少钱，但她们没法在那里卖掉它们。是的，完全正确。所以她们四处走动说，这个 Coach 钱包卖 6000 美元，就像是把价格标签留在上面一样。是的，没错，她们把美国的价格标签留在钱包上。但我想她们连一美元都卖不出去。这总是很有趣，对吧？人们谈论我们给东西赋予了多少
value on things in dollar amounts. But then, like, if you're stranded on a desert island, like, that stuff's worthless to you. Like, you don't have food and water. And it's, like, it's really all relative, like, how much something's worth. So, you know, if you're in China and there's nowhere for you to sell them and these purses are in high supply and they don't hold value. You can't do anything with them except maybe, like, burn them for, heat yourself or try to like trade them for other like collect them all like pokemon or something like this is not like i don't know like totally the the other interesting thing is they a lot of them don't feel like they're being mistreated like the hours are harsh but but
美元价值。但如果你被困在荒岛上，那些东西对你来说一文不值。比如，你没有食物和水。这真的都是相对的，东西值多少钱。所以，如果你在中国，没有地方卖它们，这些钱包供应充足，而且它们不保值。你除了把它们烧了取暖，或者试着像收集宝可梦一样收集它们，什么也做不了。这太……我不知道。另一个有趣的事情是，她们很多人并不觉得被虐待了。工作时间很长，但
there's a i guess in the chinese culture they're used to working like really long hours even when they work in the fields like a lot of them come from from rural backgrounds where they worked a lot of hours there. They said that the thing that they really want is education. And then it's really hard for these factory workers to even like learn English and things like that. Because it takes a lot of time. You have to spend a lot of time to learn. Yeah. And there's just no opportunities like there's just no they don't have classes or anything like that. And so I thought that was interesting. And in fact, the beginning
我想在中国文化中，她们习惯了长时间工作，即使在田里干活时也是如此。她们很多人来自农村背景，在那里也工作很长时间。她们说她们真正想要的是教育。但这些工厂工人很难学习英语之类的东西。因为这需要很多时间。你必须花很多时间去学习。是的。而且根本没有机会，她们没有课程之类的。所以我认为这很有趣。事实上，演讲的开头
of the talk was like, you guys are going to think that these workers are oppressed and they're just slaving away. But the reality is that the things they want aren't what you think they'd want. And the whole thing is interesting. You guys should definitely check it out. And we definitely weren't trying to be mean to anybody.
是这样的：你们会认为这些工人被压迫，只是在做苦力。但现实是，她们想要的东西并不是你们认为她们会想要的。整个故事很有趣。你们一定要去看看。我们绝对不是想对任何人刻薄。
No, not at all. And you can check it out by connecting your Raspberry Pi definitely weren't trying to be mean to anybody. No, no, not at all. Yeah. And you can check it out by connecting your Raspberry Pi up to your television if you have one. Did you get yours or did you never actually order one? No, I ended up, so yeah, basically I just decided I was either going to get a Raspberry Pi or an iPhone developer's license. Okay.
不，一点也不。你可以通过连接你的树莓派……我们绝对不是想对任何人刻薄。不，不，一点也不。是的。如果你有电视的话，可以通过连接你的树莓派来观看。你拿到你的了吗，还是你根本没订购？不，我最终……是的，基本上我决定要么买一个树莓派，要么买一个 iPhone 开发者账号。好的。
Because they're both around the same amount. Okay. And so I just went with the iPhone developer's license. Oh, okay. I see, I see. Yeah, so Raspberry Pi, we've talked about these small devices before. And they finally come into, I guess, wide-scale distribution after having, like, a huge backorder and not making them in very high quantities.
因为它们的价格差不多。好的。所以我最终选择了 iPhone 开发者账号。哦，好的，我明白了。是的，树莓派，我们之前讨论过这些小型设备。它们终于进入了，我想是大规模分销阶段，之前它们一直处于巨大的积压状态，产量也不高。
And so people are starting to come out with interesting projects. And this one is a guy at a university, and his son built a supercomputer out of Raspberry Pis and Legos. Awesome. The son had actually been learning programming through one of MIT's more visual programming languages called Scratch. I don't know much about it. Maybe we'll have to look into it in the future and add it to the list. Add it to Scratch. Scratch.
所以人们开始搞一些有趣的实验。其中一个是大学里的一位男士，他的儿子用树莓派和乐高积木造了一台超级计算机。太棒了。他儿子实际上是通过麻省理工学院的一种更直观的编程语言 Scratch 学习编程的。我不太了解它。也许我们以后得研究一下，把它加到清单里。加到 Scratch 里。Scratch。
And so they network network them all together they put all the you know high performance computing stack on it things like mpi message passing interface yeah okay um things like that and the interesting thing is they didn't have a lot of performance statistics that i saw in the article reading briefly but what's interesting is that um you know it's very difficult for for universities or small scale people to learn um the how to write programs for this style of computing so even if it's not a top 100 supercomputer that you're building just having something that's more than five or six machines but something that is like you know 20 30 40 machines and understanding where the bottlenecks are and how to write code for that and how to optimize. This is very important to do, but it could be very expensive.
他们把它们全部联网，把所有高性能计算堆栈放在上面，比如 MPI 消息传递接口。是的，好的。类似的东西。有趣的是，我在文章中看到的性能统计数据不多，但有趣的是，大学或小规模群体很难学习如何为这种计算风格编写程序。所以即使你构建的不是前 100 名的超级计算机，只要拥有超过五六台机器，比如 20、30、40 台机器，了解瓶颈在哪里，如何为之编写代码以及如何优化，这非常重要，但成本可能非常高。
And so this person spent about $4,000, it said, to make this, and it'll be an invaluable learning tool. Now, $4,000 is a little bit much for a side hobby, so it's probably hopefully for the university itself, but it's definitely an awesome learning experience and speaks to the interesting things you can do with stuff like this. Yeah, this picture is amazing. you guys should definitely read this yeah so the built the racks and cases out of lego it's phenomenal it is it is really cool um and then you know hooked them all together with it's amazing that the the circuit board is
所以这个人花了大约 4000 美元来制造这个，这将是一个无价的学习工具。现在，4000 美元作为业余爱好有点贵了，所以希望它是为大学本身准备的，但这绝对是一次很棒的学习经历，也说明了你可以用这种东西做一些有趣的事情。是的，这张照片太棒了。你们一定要读读这篇文章。是的，所以他们用乐高积木搭建了机架和外壳，这太惊人了。这真的很酷。然后你知道，把它们全部连接在一起。令人惊奇的是，电路板的布局
like laid out in such a way where the lego could perfectly fit you know i mean that's yeah well it's also interesting that it's like the scale, right? Like how small it is that Legos are about the right size. Like you don't need, it's like four or five Legos, like three Legos in one dimension and like four Legos in the other. It's like not a lot of Legos that you need. Look at the power of that. This is so awesome.
竟然能让乐高积木完美契合。我的意思是，那是……是的，有趣的是它的比例，对吧？它有多小，乐高积木的大小正好合适。你不需要很多，大概就是四个或五个乐高积木，一个维度上三个，另一个维度上四个。你需要的乐高积木并不多。看看它的威力。这太棒了。
We can see that Jason read the stories in advance. I'm totally busted. So, yeah, this is so awesome. We can see that Jason read the stories in advance. Totally busted. So, yeah, this is very interesting. And the other thing I'd be curious is people doing, and I've seen some stuff similar with Amazon, their cloud computing, right? So, you know, bringing up a bunch of computers there so you can practice and do large-scale supercomputing style work and kind of learn that work on it. Actually, along those lines there's this thing called a common crawl have you seen this no so common crawl is a 60 terabyte snapshot of the internet and uh so what you can do they have actually have code contests constantly with
我们可以看出 Jason 提前读了这些故事。我完全被抓包了。所以，是的，这太棒了。我们可以看出 Jason 提前读了这些故事。完全被抓包了。所以，是的，这非常有趣。另一件让我好奇的事情是人们在做的事情，我见过一些类似亚马逊云计算的东西，对吧？所以，你知道，在那里启动一堆计算机，这样你就可以练习并进行大规模超级计算风格的工作，并从中学习。事实上，沿着这些思路，有一个叫 Common Crawl 的东西，你见过吗？没有。所以 Common Crawl 是互联网的一个 60 TB 的快照。你可以做的是，他们实际上经常举办代码竞赛，
different themes which is kind of fun but um if you have an Amazon account, which if you're a student, you can get one at a discount or even free, you can write sort of algorithms that work on the entire Internet, and they run on Amazon EC2. And so Common Crawl is a way to sort of make it easy for people to write things like, oh, what's the co-occurrence matrix of every word on the internet or oh like let's try and do something cool with like all the twitter you know data that's public or you know things like that so um they they do a lot of fun
主题各不相同，这很有趣。但是，如果你有一个亚马逊账户（如果你是学生，可以打折甚至免费获得一个），你可以编写在整个互联网上运行的算法，它们在亚马逊 EC2 上运行。所以 Common Crawl 是一种让人们更容易编写程序的方法，比如，互联网上每个单词的共现矩阵是什么？或者让我们尝试用所有公开的 Twitter 数据做点酷的事情，或者类似的事情。所以他们做了很多有趣的事情。
stuff you guys should definitely check out interesting yeah that sounds cool it's another way to sort of like teach people about, you know, super parallel programming. Yeah, I mean, big data, right? Like I guess that's the buzzword for it. But it really is important. We see it out here being where we are in California. Everybody, everything is all about big data. Billboards on the side of the road.
你们一定要去看看。有趣，是的，听起来很酷。这是另一种教人们关于超级并行编程的方法。是的，我是说，大数据，对吧？我想那是它的流行语。但这确实很重要。我们在这里，在加利福尼亚，随处可见。每个人，每件事都与大数据有关。路边的广告牌上都是。
Yeah, it's crazy. But it is true. Like you have to take special care when you get into data that starts off the sentence like, for every website in the web, count the number of times a word occurs. How do you handle that? What data structures do you use? This is very valuable. And it is a good skill to have if you're trying to learn stuff.
是的，这很疯狂。但这是真的。当你处理以“对于网络上的每个网站，计算一个单词出现的次数”开头的句子时，你必须特别小心。你如何处理它？你使用什么数据结构？这非常有价值。如果你想学习东西，这是一个很好的技能。
Yeah, totally. Totally. So our final news article is kind of a little bit silly. But somebody wrote about making a Turing-complete computer using three Magic the Gathering cards. So Magic the Gathering brings a little nostalgia for me, is a collectible card game. So it's a card game that has all these different kinds of cards,
是的，完全正确。完全正确。所以我们的最后一个新闻文章有点傻。但有人写了关于使用三张《万智牌》制作一台图灵完备计算机的文章。《万智牌》带给我一点怀旧感，它是一款集换式卡牌游戏。所以它是一款拥有各种不同卡牌的卡牌游戏，
and some are rare and very rare, and some are very common. And there's a set of rules, and basically you try to build up a deck that's your favorite deck. And you play your buddies with your cards and see who's the best or whatever. This was before the internet was really big. Well, maybe it was different than it was today. So we had to spend time outside. Did you get into it? So into it was different.
有些很稀有，非常稀有，有些很常见。有一套规则，基本上你尝试构建一副你最喜欢的套牌。你用你的卡牌和朋友们玩，看看谁最厉害之类的。这还是在互联网普及之前。好吧，也许它和今天不一样。所以我们必须花时间在户外。你玩过吗？所以玩的时候感觉不一样。
I never like, so it can be very expensive to acquire the very rare cards and stuff. Although they've gone up in value. Like I kind of wish I had bought them and then sold them today. But we would play. We would go to the store that sold them and buy the pack of common cards. The box of 400 for $5. And then we would just play games, me and brothers and I. I did the same thing at school.
我从来没有……所以获取那些非常稀有的卡牌可能会非常昂贵。虽然它们现在升值了。我有点希望我当时买了，然后今天卖掉。但我们会玩。我们会去卖卡牌的商店买普通卡牌包。400 张一盒，5 美元。然后我们就会玩游戏，我和我兄弟们。我在学校也做过同样的事。
The really cheap stuff. Our decks were horrible, right? But it didn't matter because as long as everybody else's deck is horrible, it's still fun. If you've never heard of it before, you can check it out. They recently released a program
那些非常便宜的东西。我们的套牌很糟糕，对吧？但这没关系，因为只要其他人的套牌也很糟糕，它依然很有趣。如果你以前没听说过，你可以去看看。他们最近发布了一个程序
for Magic the Gathering that has a lot of cards in it and hosts games online. I think they have an iPad, iPhone. It's actually, considering how much it can be to buy a real deck and play it, it it's it's fairly affordable is it you have to pay per card so the way i think it works is like you can buy pre-constructed decks of cards or you can pay for like random things similar to like buying booster packs or whatever um which is kind of interesting maybe we'll have to talk about gaming sometime because a lot of cool games but uh so
用于《万智牌》，里面有很多卡牌，可以在线托管游戏。我想他们有 iPad 和 iPhone 版。实际上，考虑到购买一副真正的套牌并玩它可能需要多少钱，它相当实惠。是吗？你必须按卡牌付费。我想它的工作方式是你可以购买预先构建的卡牌套牌，或者你可以为随机的东西付费，类似于购买补充包之类的。这很有趣，也许我们以后得谈谈游戏，因为有很多很酷的游戏。但是，
this person found essentially Turing Complete is named after Alan Turing, who showed that there exists a computer that if it can do a certain set of routines, can perform any computing function. It can compute anything that's possible or whatever. So it's essentially showing that if you have a programming language or a computer that's Turing Complete, that given enough time and possibly infinite time, it can accomplish any given computing task. And so this person had three cards with unique properties that involve counters.
这个人发现，本质上，“图灵完备”是以艾伦·图灵命名的，他证明了存在这样一种计算机，如果它能执行一组特定的例程，就能执行任何计算功能。它可以计算任何可能的事情。所以这本质上是在证明，如果你有一种编程语言或计算机是图灵完备的，那么在有足够时间（可能是无限时间）的情况下，它可以完成任何给定的计算任务。所以这个人有三张具有涉及计数器的独特属性的卡牌。
And the idea of a Turing machine is it's a tape head moving on an infinite tape and kind of storing data in one place and then having an instruction that tells it what to move left or right and then what to do when it gets there, that kind of thing. And so they were able to do that with these three cards. It was kind of interesting. It's kind of silly, but it's kind of fun to read about. Yeah, it's amazing. Yeah, I see what people do these things every once in a while, build a working computer out of Legos or ball bearings
图灵机的概念是一个磁带头在无限磁带上移动，在一个地方存储数据，然后有一个指令告诉它向左或向右移动，然后在到达那里时做什么，诸如此类。所以他们能够用这三张卡牌做到这一点。这很有趣。有点傻，但读起来很有意思。是的，太神奇了。是的，我偶尔会看到人们做这些事情，用乐高积木或滚珠轴承
or Magic the Gathering cards. Did you see the one in Minecraft that was made out of Minecraft animals and water? Oh, I haven't seen that one, no. I've seen the ones where they use the, what is that called, the redstone and make the wires. And actually, people built a game. So it has a giant screen that displays stuff and has a graphics processing unit and everything.
或《万智牌》卡牌建造一台能工作的计算机。你见过 Minecraft 里那个用 Minecraft 动物和水做的吗？哦，我没见过那个，没有。我见过那些使用所谓的红石来制作电线的人。事实上，人们建造了一个游戏。所以它有一个显示东西的巨大屏幕，还有一个图形处理器等等。
That's awesome. Oh, man, it's such crazy. That's great. I guess that's one of those things that people say about guitar hero whatever like if you spend that much time playing guitar hero you just learn to play real guitar that's not exactly the truth but it's the same thing like oh you just spend that much time like creating minecraft things like that's crazy like it's awesome and it's dedication and they're having fun so more power to them like i don't think but it's like
那太棒了。哦，天哪，太疯狂了。那太棒了。我想这就是人们对《吉他英雄》之类的游戏所说的那样，如果你花那么多时间玩《吉他英雄》，你就能学会弹真正的吉他。这不完全是事实，但道理是一样的。比如，哦，你花那么多时间创造 Minecraft 的东西，这太疯狂了，太棒了，这是奉献精神，而且他们玩得很开心，所以祝他们好运。我不认为……但这就像
wow like i wonder what other stuff you could do with that much time like yeah i noticed i was watching a youtube video the other day where somebody had a like a minecraft i guess you could export your world and like send it to people and they can import it and this guy had made a world which was like a rpg and you had to like the thing is the onus was on you to follow the rules like of course you could just punch your way through the wall and be done but like assuming you followed the rules like, the thing is the onus was on you to follow the rules. Like, of course, you could just punch your way through the wall and be done. But, like, assuming you followed the rules, like, it was just, like, pretty fun, like, semi-random, like, RPG. And I thought that was awesome. And so I think there needs to be, like, a database of, like, Minecraft worlds.
哇，我想知道如果你把那么多时间花在其他事情上会怎样。是的，我前几天在看一个 YouTube 视频，有人有一个 Minecraft……我想你可以导出你的世界，然后发给别人，他们可以导入。这个家伙做了一个世界，就像一个 RPG，你必须……问题是，责任在于你自己去遵守规则。当然，你可以直接打穿墙壁然后结束，但假设你遵守规则，它就像是一个非常有趣的、半随机的 RPG。我觉得这太棒了。所以我认为需要有一个 Minecraft 世界的数据库。
There probably is, dude. There's, like, everything. So it's so interesting, Minecraft, that the guy Marcus Pierce. Is that Marcus Pierce? Yeah, Marcus Person. I don't know. Okay. They call him Notch.
可能已经有了，伙计。什么都有。所以 Minecraft 太有趣了，那个叫 Marcus Pierce 的人。是 Marcus Pierce 吗？是的，Marcus Person。我不知道。好的。他们叫他 Notch。
Yeah. You know, he, like, made something that, you know, took him some time and work. And he's kind of become famous. But a lot of it is due to the openness. Like, not just the game is an open world, but, like, it's open to modification and sharing levels and hacking save games and creating macros. And he kind of incorporates stuff that people do and brings it back in. And now he doesn't actually work on it anymore.
是的。你知道，他做了一些花了他时间和精力的事情。他变得很有名。但很大程度上是因为开放性。不仅游戏是一个开放世界，而且它对修改、分享关卡、破解存档游戏和创建宏是开放的。他把人们做的事情整合起来，并带回游戏里。现在他实际上不再参与开发了。
He has his team works on it or whatever. He does other stuff. Yeah, he's working on that space sim. The space one, yeah. I don't know how you say it, but you can look it up. And it's kind of similar. So it's interesting that he embraced the openness of the community so much
他有他的团队在负责。他在做其他事情。是的，他在做那个太空模拟游戏。那个太空游戏，是的。我不知道怎么读，但你可以查一下。它有点类似。所以有趣的是，他如此拥抱社区的开放性，
and that they've really kind of embraced him back. And people see these crazy YouTube videos and then go buy a copy of his game, right? Yeah, I was thinking about getting it for the phone. I just don't know how good it's going to be. I have it for my Xbox. And the cool thing about the Xbox is, since the game really is meant to kind of run in like 640x480
而社区也真正拥抱了他。人们看到这些疯狂的 YouTube 视频，然后去买他的游戏，对吧？是的，我正在考虑给手机买一个。我只是不知道效果会怎样。我的 Xbox 上有这个游戏。Xbox 的酷之处在于，因为游戏本身确实是在 640x480
or 800x600, because it's really pixelated and blocky, so you can make it bigger but you're not really getting any more data on the screen. And so I have like a nicey so you can make it bigger but you're not really getting any more data on the screen right um and so i have like a nice tv you know hd resolution and xbox can push that so you can actually play four players simultaneously on one screen like sitting there with xbox controllers and you although your screen gets smaller right like you still have the same data that's on there yeah so it works pretty well so that's cool play with people sitting in the same room which is kind of fun. Yeah, yeah.
或 800x600 下运行的，因为它非常像素化和块状，所以你可以把它放大，但屏幕上并没有获得更多数据。所以我有一台不错的电视，高清分辨率，Xbox 可以支持，所以你实际上可以在一个屏幕上同时玩四人游戏，坐在那里用 Xbox 控制器。虽然你的屏幕变小了，但你仍然拥有相同的数据。是的，所以它运行得很好，这很酷。和坐在同一个房间里的人一起玩，这很有趣。是的，是的。
That's great. But I don't have it on my phone yet. Yeah. I'll probably get the demo maybe today or tomorrow. All right. So if you don't do any work
那太棒了。但我手机上还没有。是的。我可能今天或明天会下载演示版。好的。所以如果你接下来一两周不做任何工作的话。事实上，我手机上没有它的原因是因为我们的“本周工具”。哦哦。工具的……
for the next week or two. Actually, so the reason why I don't have it on my phone is because of our tool of the buy week. Uh-oh. Tool of the...
我们没同步说出来。好的。继续。我们的三个工具……哦，我又错过了。好的，继续。继续吧。好的。
We didn't say it in sync. Okay. Continue. Our three tool... Oh, I missed it again. Okay, just continue. Just go. All right.
所以我的本周工具实际上是游戏《地牢爬行：石头汤》。你又要浪费我的时间了吗？我是不是真的要冒着因为不做工作而被解雇的风险？这可能会导致你被解雇，但这是值得的。你会成为一个快乐的……你怎么能确定它对我来说值得？事实上，“值得”可能不是最好的词，但……所以我选择这个是因为
So my tool of the bye week is actually game dungeon crawl stone soup. Are you going to waste more of my time? Like, am I literally going to risk getting fired for not doing work? This might cause you to get fired, but it'll be worth it. You'll be a happy'll be you'll be how can you determine if it's worth it for me actually worth it might not be the best choice of words but uh so this i picked this for a
很多原因。一个是它有一个很棒的教程，这是 Roguelike 游戏（这是一款 Roguelike 游戏）通常很糟糕的地方。如果你去玩《NetHack》，它一开始就是：选择你的角色，选择你的种族，你根本不知道它们是什么。然后它就说，去吧，试试《矮人要塞》。是的，《矮人要塞》是最糟糕的。我愿意付出一切来获得一个很棒的教程。他们有一本书，人们对此赞不绝口，所以这有点疯狂，你必须读一本书。教科书。就像《矮人要塞》傻瓜书之类的。它就像一本 O'Reilly 的书。上面有一只猫头鹰。
number of reasons uh one is um it has an awesome tutorial which is something that like roguelikes which this is a roguelike um are notoriously bad at like if you go to play nethack it starts off you know pick your role pick your race you don't know what any of them really are and then it's like go yeah try dwarf fortress yeah dwarf fortress is the worst i would kill to have an awesome tutorial they have a book that people are like raving about that like it's so it's kind of crazy you have to read like a book. Textbook. It's like a Dwarf Fortress for idiots or something. It's like an O'Reilly book. It has an owl on it.
不，事实上，我想它是 O'Reilly 的。但它不是猫头鹰。好的，我现在就去查一下。但我真的很想买它，因为每个玩这个游戏的人都说它太棒了。比如所有这些非常有名的人，甚至 Notch，对吧？那个制作 Minecraft 的人。他从中获得了灵感，所以……《矮人要塞》是我有史以来最喜欢的游戏，对于不知道的人来说，它太棒了。但是的，你有一个巨大的学习曲线。是的，我真的
No, actually, I think it is O'Reilly. But it's not an owl. All right, I'm going to look it up right now. But I'm really tempted to buy it because everybody who gets in this game just says it's amazing. Like all these really famous people, like even Notch, right? Like the guy who made Minecraft. Like he took inspiration from like it's so. Dwarf Fortress is my favorite game of all time for people who don't know um it's amazing but yeah you're a gigantic learning curve yeah i really
想深入了解它，但我必须投入大量时间才能开始，而且那只是冰山一角，然后我还要花更多时间去探索。为什么《矮人要塞》很棒，如果我必须用一句话概括，那就是它汲取了 Minecraft 最好的部分，即创造性的建筑部分，但它把它放在了一个你真正想要的环境中。它把它放在了一个模拟环境中，就像在 Minecraft 中，你必须亲自走过地图，或者你必须盖房子，你知道你想盖什么，但你必须点击所有的方块。所以《矮人要塞》你可以布置一个小平面图并下达指令，然后你的小人们就可以四处走动执行这些小指令。而且它有永久死亡，
want to get into it but it's like i'd have to invest so much time just to get started and then like that's only the tip of the iceberg then i'm gonna spend tons more time yeah exploring the reason why doorforge is great just if i had to say it in one sentence it would be you know it takes like the best of minecraft which is a creative like building part but to say it in one sentence it would be you know it takes like the best of Minecraft which is a creative like building part but it puts it in an environment where you really want it it puts it in a sim like like in Minecraft you have to actually walk across the map right or like you have to build a house and you know what you want to build but you have to click on all the blocks right so door forges you can lay out like a little floor plan and give orders and then your guys can go around you know doing these little orders and also it has permadeath
你知道，因为你有所有这些矮人，如果你犯了错误，比如你挖得太深，有你无法处理的怪物，你的矮人就会死。所以那种永久死亡给了你一种悬疑感，我觉得 Minecraft 里没有那么多。所以，这本书叫《矮人要塞入门》，由 O'Reilly 出版。我听说过关于它的好评，人们说它应该非常好。所以如果你对《矮人要塞》感兴趣，并且想浪费几个月的时间，一定要买那本书。如果你买了，告诉我进展如何。好的，我会借给你的。好的，好的，那就这样吧。不，请不要。我妻子可能不会很高兴。这也不仅仅是 Marcus Person，是的，这里有一个……总之，是的，我们
you know because you have all these dwarfs and you're getting like a new supply of dwarfs if you make a mistake like you dig too deep and there are monsters you can't handle um your dwarfs die and so that permadeath gives you like a level of suspense i feel like you don't really have as much in minecraft so um so the game the book is called getting started with dwarf fortress by o'reilly i've heard good things about it like people like it's supposed to be really really good so if you're interested in dwarf fortress and like wasting i'm months of your life definitely buying that book if you do let me know how it goes yeah i'll loan it to you okay all all right there you go there you go no please don't my wife my wife might like not be very happy with you or me it's also not not just marcus person yeah here's a per anyways yeah so we're
可能读错了，但我们给了他们赞誉。回到你的话题，我完全跑题了。所以，是的，别担心。所以《地牢爬行：石头汤》有一个很棒的教程，它教你如何开始游戏，不同的按键，你知道……一些很多人玩《NetHack》和这些 Roguelike 游戏时没有意识到的事情是，如果你按住 Shift 键并向一个方向移动，你的角色会走那么多步，直到他撞到墙或撞到有趣的东西。所以很多人不知道这一点，所以他们一直按左、左、左、左，他们只是浪费了很多时间，因为游戏是回合制的。
probably saying it wrong but we're giving them credit so back to your topic which i totally derailed so uh yeah no worries so this has dungeon crawl stone soup has an amazing tutorial and it teaches you about you know getting started with the game the different keys you know um some things a lot of people play net hack and slash them these roguelikes the thing they don't realize is if you um hold shift and you move a direction your character will walk that many steps until he either like hits a wall or hits like something interesting and so a lot of people don't know that and so they keep hitting like left left left left and they're just wasting a lot of time you know because the game is like kind of turn
它是为你能够使用宏而设计的，这些宏在所有这些 Roguelike 游戏中都是通用的。所以《地牢爬行：石头汤》是一种让你进入状态，让你以它们本应有的节奏玩 Roguelike 游戏，并从你的 Roguelike 游戏中获得更多乐趣的方法。除了教程之外，它本身也是一款非常棒的游戏。我还没玩太多，但它有各种各样的法术、能力、种族和职业。是的，我听说过这个作为 Roguelike 游戏的入门作品很不错。是的，它应该非常好，而且也非常深奥，对吧？是的，是的，绝对。我手机上有它，所以玩起来非常有趣。
based it's like designed for you to be able to sort of macro and there's all these macros and they're all common across all these roguelikes so dungeon crawl stone soups a way to sort of get you in there and get you like working in roguelikes playing roguelikes like at the pace they're meant to be played and just getting like a ton more fun out of your roguelike um on top of the tutorial it's also just an all-around great game like i haven't played a lot of it yet but um has like a wide array of different spells and abilities you can use and races and classes and yeah i've heard good stuff about this as like an introduction to roguelikes yeah it's supposed to be really good but it's also really deep right yeah yeah definitely i have it on my phone and uh so it's been it's been pretty fun
它基本上是为你设计的，让你能够使用宏，而且这些宏在所有Roguelike游戏中都是通用的，所以《地牢爬行：石头汤》是一种让你上手并以应有的节奏去游玩Roguelike游戏的方式，能让你从Roguelike游戏中获得更多乐趣。除了教程之外，它本身也是一款非常棒的游戏。虽然我还没玩太多，但它有各种各样的法术、能力、种族和职业。是的，我听说过它作为Roguelike游戏的入门作评价很好。没错，它被认为非常出色，但同时也非常有深度。是的，确实如此。我的手机上装了它，玩起来非常有趣。
i'm looking at the screenshots and how deep and cool the nerdy this looks there's something appealing i don't know what it is like right something that looks very difficult and very nerdy and like elitist like you want to do it just because like you want to it's like what do they call it wearing the hair shirt or whatever yeah exactly it's like you want to put on the thing that's itchy and bothers you just to like prove like yeah i am elite nerd yeah exactly yeah the um the uh they post the high scores and they post a list of all the people who have completed the game online so that can get pretty addictive like you want to be on that list. I don't think so.
我看着那些截图，觉得这种书呆子气看起来既深奥又酷，有一种莫名的吸引力，我不知道是什么，就像是那种看起来非常困难、非常书呆子气、甚至有点精英主义的东西，你就是想去尝试，仅仅是因为你想做。这就像人们所说的“穿苦行衫”之类的，没错，就是这样，你就是想穿上那件让你发痒、让你难受的衣服，只是为了证明“没错，我就是精英书呆子”。没错，他们会在网上发布高分榜和所有通关玩家的名单，这会让人上瘾，因为你想出现在那个名单上。我不这么认为。
Oh, really? I think that's like, you make it there, and you feel so proud of yourself for like a day. And then you look at it, and you're just like, ah. It's like getting the high score on an arcade game until they reset it, right? I'm still proud of, so NetHack has a server of it, like this sort, too.
哦，真的吗？我觉得就像是，你达到了那个目标，你会为自己感到自豪，大概持续一天吧。然后你再看一眼，就会觉得，啊。这就像在街机游戏里拿到高分，直到他们重置分数一样，对吧？我依然为之自豪，NetHack也有这样的服务器。
And I've ascended in NetHack on the server, and I'm still proud of it to this day. Like, I still, every now and then I look back, and I'm like, yeah. Good job. Good job, sir. Pat on the back. And Slashem, which is a harder version of NetHack,
我在服务器上通关过NetHack，直到今天我依然为此感到自豪。就像，我偶尔回想起来，会觉得，没错。干得好。干得好，先生。给自己拍拍肩膀。而Slashem，作为NetHack的一个更难版本，
also has this. And I've tried, you know, on and off for half of my life. I've never done it. Never ascended in. One time I went, like, halfway, which, you know, is like 40 hours of gameplay I don't by the way
也有这个功能。我断断续续尝试了半辈子，但从来没通关过。有一次我玩到了一半，那大概是40个小时的游戏时间。顺便说一下，
if you're a game developer or thinking about becoming a game developer please stop putting how many hours I've played your game oh I know please stop
如果你是游戏开发者，或者正打算成为游戏开发者，请停止显示我玩了你们游戏多少小时，哦，我知道，请停止。
it's so bad please stop don't do that Steam does that on all the games now and it just makes me depressed every time I look at it
这太糟糕了，请停止，别那样做。Steam现在在所有游戏上都这么干，每次我看到它都让我感到沮丧。
yeah okay my tool of the bi-week is not a game. It's Wireshark. That's a great tool. So Wireshark used to be called something before. Ethereal?
好吧，我这双周推荐的工具不是游戏，是Wireshark。那是个很棒的工具。Wireshark以前叫别的名字吧？Ethereal？
Yeah, that's right. So this is the kind of thing that you either love and you use it all the time, or you hate and you've never used it before, or you get into a bind and you don't know how to do something or what to do, and then you use this. And that is,
没错。所以这东西要么是你热爱并一直使用的，要么是你讨厌且从未用过的，或者当你陷入困境、不知道该怎么做或该做什么时，你就会用到它。那就是，
any time you're going to do network programming, and it's so hard to tell what's happening when you try to open that socket and it just doesn't work. You don't know if packets are getting there. Are they malformed? What's going on? And Wireshark is kind of the answer to that. Or if you're using BitTorrent and it's telling you,
任何时候当你进行网络编程时，当你尝试打开那个套接字却无法工作时，很难判断发生了什么。你不知道数据包是否到达了，它们是否格式错误？到底怎么了？而Wireshark就是解决这个问题的答案。或者如果你在使用BitTorrent，它提示你，
hey, your port is closed or whatever, and you just can't seem to figure it out, Wireshark will tell you, oh, you have packets coming out of your computer, so it must be somewhere else in the chain. Yeah, so what Wireshark does is it puts your Ethernet port into a mode where basically it can read all of the packets you're getting along with everything else still getting the packets like normal. So everything acts like normal, but Wireshark is getting a copy of all the packets as well. And then what it does is just kind of displays like a hex dump of the packets,
嘿，你的端口已关闭之类的，你似乎无法弄清楚原因，Wireshark会告诉你，哦，你的电脑确实发出了数据包，所以问题肯定出在链路的其他地方。没错，Wireshark的作用是把你以太网端口置于一种模式，基本上它可以读取你收到的所有数据包，同时其他程序也能像往常一样接收数据包。所以一切运行正常，但Wireshark也获得了一份所有数据包的副本。然后它所做的就是显示这些数据包的十六进制转储，
like the header, the information, whatever. But then it has these processors that get layered on top to understand like HTTP traffic. So like, oh, this is a get request, you know, and it'll actually like try to kind of tell you in an intelligent, readable way all of those things that you might want to know about that kind of information. And it's just one of those things like if you need this, it's just really valuable
比如头部信息、数据内容等等。但它还有一些分层处理器来理解HTTP流量。所以它会显示，哦，这是一个GET请求，你知道，它实际上会尝试以一种智能、可读的方式告诉你所有你可能想知道的信息。这属于那种如果你需要它，它就非常有价值的东西，
and works really well. But it can be it's like a power users tool, like 90% of people probably never who do a lot of computer programming never use it and never get into it, but you know it can be really helpful and it's good to know about. Yeah, definitely. Especially if you're doing any kind of network development.
而且非常好用。但它更像是一个高级用户工具，可能90%做大量计算机编程的人从不使用它，也从不接触它，但你知道它真的很有帮助，了解一下是件好事。没错，绝对是。特别是如果你在做任何类型的网络开发的话。
Yeah. I mean, if you're doing it. I made that 90% up. No, I'm thinking about it. I have no idea what percentage. Like 99. I don't know. Okay, sorry.
是啊。我是说，如果你在做的话。那90%是我瞎编的。不，我想了一下。我不知道具体百分比。可能是99%。我不知道。好吧，抱歉。
But, you know, it's awesome. I wrote a peer-to-peer app, and Wireshark was, like, crucial. Because, I mean, you know you it was sort of kind of like based on a heuristic who would connect to who and things like that and wireshark like explicitly was telling me oh you know these ports are talking to these ports you know on the same machine and things like that so so uh if you're doing any kind of network programming this will save your life yep save your time all right time for basic history of BASIC is that it was created in Dartmouth College out of a research paper. So some programming languages are created by
但是，你知道，它太棒了。我写过一个点对点应用，Wireshark简直至关重要。因为，你知道，它有点基于启发式算法来决定谁连接谁之类的，而Wireshark明确地告诉我，哦，你知道这些端口正在和同一台机器上的那些端口通信之类的。所以，如果你在做任何类型的网络编程，这会救你的命。没错，节省你的时间。好了，现在是BASIC的基础历史时间。它是在达特茅斯学院根据一篇研究论文创建的。所以有些编程语言是由
programmers and some by researchers who I guess could be considered programmers as well. But we're kind of doing research topic and we're talking like way back in the day. So what we're saying is like the 60s or pre-60s, like in the 50s. Yeah, totally. We should get the year. I think like the early 60s. I'm totally unprepared. I'll look this up. It's okay. And it was based on a paper.
程序员创建的，有些是由研究人员创建的，我想他们也可以被视为程序员。但我们是在谈论研究课题，而且是很久以前的事了。所以我们说的是60年代或60年代之前，比如50年代。没错，完全正确。我们应该查查年份。我想是60年代初。我完全没准备。我查一下。没关系。它是基于一篇论文的。
1964. 1964, all right. And so it's called Beginner's All-Purpose Symbolic Instruction Code. That's what the acronym is. The acronym, so basic. And the whole idea was that, you know, there were programming languages at the time,
1964年。1964年，好的。所以它被称为“初学者通用符号指令代码”。这就是缩写。这个缩写，就是BASIC。整个想法是，你知道，当时已经有编程语言了，
but it all kind of like assumed you were like a hardcore programmer like you wanted to really get into this and this was supposed to be accessible which i i mean i think it succeeds at yeah like i mean like it trying to and this is something we talked about a little before we started the show jace and i both have we'll get to him in a minute you know experiences with basic but i mean this idea this romantic notion of creating a programming language where you just describe in English sentences or insert whatever language you speak, a native language, you know, just normal conversational text to a computer and have it do what you want. I mean, this is like the Jetsons, right? You tell Rosie, like, hey, I need this,
但它们都假设你是一个硬核程序员，你想深入研究这些，而BASIC应该是易于使用的，我的意思是，我认为它成功了。没错，我的意思是，它在尝试，这是我们在节目开始前稍微讨论过的一点，杰斯和我（我们一会儿会提到他）都有过BASIC的经验，但我的意思是，这种浪漫的想法——创造一种编程语言，你只需用英语句子，或者插入你说的任何语言，母语，你知道，只是正常的对话文本给计算机，让它做你想做的事。我的意思是，这就像《杰森一家》，对吧？你告诉罗西，嘿，我需要这个，
right? And you just speak to the computer normally and it decides what to do. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you know, there's, you can't get more accessible than, you know, it being your operating system, right? Like, you turn on the computer and basic starts, you know? Yeah, so that was the way, you know, Commodore 64s, TRS-80s, Apple IIs, right? They boot them up and they just were in a basic interpreter. And it worked well for that because you could say things like, it wasn't print def or see out or what are these things.
对吧？你只是正常地和计算机说话，它就决定做什么。没错。我的意思是，你知道，没有比它成为你的操作系统更易用的了，对吧？你打开电脑，BASIC就开始了，你知道吗？没错，这就是当时的方式，你知道，Commodore 64、TRS-80、Apple II，对吧？它们启动时就直接进入了BASIC解释器。这很有效，因为你可以说类似的话，它不是printf或cout，或者这些是什么东西。
It was like print. And then you just gave it, you know, this thing you wanted it to print. And then the next line, so you say print hello world. And the next line, go to previous line, right? Go to 10. 10, print hello world. 20, go to 10. You know, yeah, if you think about it, go-tos are, so, you know, you hear all these things like go to is evil and all stuff and then somebody proved that you know this wasn't a hard proof or anything but that you could basically like if you use for
它就像是print。然后你只需给它，你知道，你想打印的东西。然后下一行，所以你说print hello world。下一行，go to上一行，对吧？10，print hello world。20，go to 10。你知道，是的，如果你想想看，go-to是，所以，你知道，你听到所有这些说法，比如go to是邪恶的等等，然后有人证明了，你知道，这不是什么硬性证明，但你可以基本上，如果你使用for
loops and breaks and returns um you can like take any program that has go to's and turn it into for loops and breaks so go to's aren't necessary yeah so yeah they're not necessary and they're also not evil like you could do the same thing you could do you could do equally evil things without using go to um but but there's there's a appeal to it you know the idea that like i'm going to label this line as like line eight and then somewhere else like go to eight like it's so much more intuitive than like a for loop where you have to like count up and each time this i has a different value and you know it might not be the most useful but for someone who's just starting out it it makes more sense like they look at that and they know immediately what's going on yeah it is true i mean the for loop concept takes a while to get around you just kind of have to get to that
循环、break和return，你可以把任何带有go to的程序转换成for循环和break，所以go to不是必须的。没错，所以它们不是必须的，而且它们也不是邪恶的，你可以做同样的事情，你可以在不使用go to的情况下做同样邪恶的事情。但是，它有一种吸引力，你知道，那种想法，比如我要把这一行标记为第8行，然后在其他地方go to 8，它比for循环直观得多，在for循环里你必须计数，每次这个i都有不同的值，你知道，它可能不是最有用的，但对于刚入门的人来说，它更有意义，他们看着它，立刻就知道发生了什么。没错，确实如此，我的意思是，for循环的概念需要一段时间才能理解，你必须达到那个
epiphany stage like oh i get it now yeah and i mean the whole issue that as programmers we understand is you need to be able to be very precise to the end and actually saying go to this line i mean that's like very if you say return it's like return to what an early basic didn't have functions or procedures it's just you know straight down the line imperative programming just you know yeah actually we should mention that we're not covering visual base yes okay we'll go through so like the first generations of basic right like there's you had to have every number lined.
顿悟阶段，哦，我现在明白了。没错，我的意思是，作为程序员我们理解的整个问题是，你需要能够非常精确，而实际上说“go to这一行”，我的意思是，如果你说return，那就像是返回到什么？早期的BASIC没有函数或过程，它只是，你知道，直截了当的命令式编程，只是，你知道，是的，实际上我们应该提到我们不讨论Visual Basic。是的，好的，我们会讲完，所以像第一代BASIC，对吧，你必须给每一行编号。
There weren't procedures. You could do these go-tos, and you could have kind of Boolean statements or whatever. Yeah. So for people who don't know, the way the computer, and Patrick will probably know a lot better than I will, so I'll let him correct me. But the way I understand it is you have a program counter. So if you have a multi-threaded. The CPU has a program counter. So if you have a multi-threaded... The CPU has a program counter. The CPU has a program counter for each thread, which says what instruction that thread is on.
没有过程。你可以使用这些go-to，你可以有某种布尔语句之类的。没错。所以对于不知道的人来说，计算机的方式，帕特里克可能比我了解得多得多，所以我让他纠正我。但我理解的方式是，你有一个程序计数器。所以如果你有一个多线程的……CPU有一个程序计数器。所以如果你有一个多线程的……CPU有一个程序计数器。CPU为每个线程都有一个程序计数器，它说明该线程正在执行哪条指令。
Or in the case of BASIC, you just have one, which is for your thread. And so the program counter keeps stepping through until it encounters a branch. So a branch might be an if statement. So if something is true, then you're going to go to the next program counter. Otherwise, you're going to skip all the way down to the end of that if block, right?
或者在BASIC的情况下，你只有一个，就是为你那个线程准备的。所以程序计数器不断地步进，直到遇到一个分支。所以分支可能是一个if语句。所以如果某事为真，那么你将跳转到下一个程序计数器。否则，你将跳过整个if块，直接跳到最后，对吧？
Or a go-to is an explicit branch. You're actually saying, you know, take the program counter and set it to this other instruction. Well, in BASIC, it makes that, like, very explicit. Like, in the first version of BASIC, you literally wrote the program counter for all of your instructions. Yeah, well, so you write the memory location essentially is what you're doing. So we say 10, and that's like a line number, because line numbers don't have to be sequential. But you're essentially kind of stating like this is an abstracted version of memory. So the processor would just execute the first memory instruction, then go to the next one, and go to the next one, until I encounter, like you said, one of these things which said,
或者go-to是一个显式分支。你实际上是在说，你知道，获取程序计数器并将其设置为另一个指令。嗯，在BASIC中，它使这一点变得非常明确。比如在第一个版本的BASIC中，你实际上是为你所有的指令编写程序计数器。没错，好吧，所以你编写的本质上是内存位置。所以我们说10，那就像一个行号，因为行号不必是连续的。但你本质上是在陈述，这是一种内存的抽象版本。所以处理器只会执行第一个内存指令，然后转到下一个，再转到下一个，直到我遇到，像你说的，这些东西之一，它说，
affect the program counter in this way. Change it to this, or minus one, or plus one, or whatever. And so basic, yeah, you had to put the line numbers there so you knew where you were, and they had to be increasing so that you would keep moving forward in the memory and going up, unless you did a go to. And then the second generation, oh, we should say that Microsoft got its start
以这种方式影响程序计数器。把它改成这个，或者减一，或者加一，或者其他什么。所以BASIC，是的，你必须把行号放在那里，这样你就知道你在哪里，而且它们必须是递增的，这样你才能在内存中继续前进并向上移动，除非你执行了一个go to。然后是第二代，哦，我们应该说微软起家于
in creating a version of BASIC and that's kind of where they started. So we won't get into that large history. I don't know if this is still true but the last time I checked which was XP it actually has QBASIC in it. Like if you just
创建一个版本的BASIC，这就是他们开始的地方。所以我们不会深入探讨那段宏大的历史。我不知道这是否仍然属实，但上次我检查时，也就是XP，它实际上里面有QBASIC。就像如果你只是
scan your whole computer for QBASIC.exe now I don't know anything about Vista or 7 but I know like 98 and XP in these 2000 actually had QBasic and they actually in the same directory there is a bananas.bas and
现在扫描你的整台电脑寻找QBASIC.exe，我不知道Vista或7的情况，但我知道98和XP以及2000确实有QBasic，而且它们在同一个目录下有一个bananas.bas，
it's a game where you're like a monkey and you have to throw a banana. It's a game written in QBasic. I don't believe you. I'm going to go try that. I'm going to go try this right now. So that was the first generation of Basic. And then the second generation came out. And this is Quick Basic, like you're talking about QBasic.
这是一个游戏，你扮演一只猴子，必须扔香蕉。这是一个用QBasic写的游戏。我不相信你。我要去试试。我现在就要去试试。所以那是第一代BASIC。然后第二代出来了。这就是Quick Basic，就像你说的QBasic。
This is where this came out. And these, you didn't have to put line numbers if you didn't want. You could have more just labels as opposed to line numbers. And then you could actually have procedures, essentially functions. You could go to a function. And then like we said said that notion of return from a function is kind of vague like where are you returning to well it depends on where you came from so when you say go to you're
这就是它出现的地方。这些，如果你不想的话，不必写行号。你可以有更多的标签而不是行号。然后你实际上可以有过程，本质上就是函数。你可以跳转到一个函数。然后就像我们说的，从函数返回的概念有点模糊，比如你返回到哪里？嗯，这取决于你从哪里来，所以当你执行go to时，你
going to a line and then you have to later you say go to some other line like you it's not just like go the return is go to something that was stored previously and that's the the stack so the stack will store have Have we talked about stack? No, I don't think we have. All right, why don't you cover it? I think you'd be an expert on this. So for people who don't know, Patrick majored in computer engineering, and I majored in computer science.
跳转到一行，然后你必须稍后说go to其他行，就像你，它不仅仅是go，return是go to之前存储的某个东西，那就是栈。所以栈会存储……我们谈过栈吗？不，我不认为我们谈过。好吧，你为什么不讲讲？我想你会是这方面的专家。所以对于不知道的人，帕特里克主修计算机工程，我主修计算机科学。
And then that alone makes him, like, much more applied and know things which are useful. I mean, no crazy five-minute time. I think we're overstating this. But then, like, on top of that, I did all theory. Like, I tried to stay away from all the like databases and networking and so that makes me even more even like less useful when it comes like close to the metal stuff so so patrick okay okay so a stack is a data structure but also it's
仅凭这一点就让他，比如，更具应用能力，知道一些有用的东西。我的意思是，没有疯狂的五分钟时间。我想我们夸大其词了。但随后，比如，除此之外，我做了所有的理论。比如，我尽量远离所有那些数据库和网络之类的东西，所以这让我甚至更，甚至更不擅长处理底层的东西，所以，所以帕特里克，好的，好的，所以栈是一种数据结构，但它也是
something that is represented in the hardware in cpus. And it is what's called a last in, first out data structure. So this implies that the last piece of data that you gave to the data structure, when you go to get something from it, it'll be the first thing that comes out. So think of it as like, it's called a stack. It's like a stack of papers. If you put one paper down, then put another on top and another on top, when you go to pull that last one, to pull the one on top, it's the most recent one you put there.
在CPU硬件中表示的东西。它被称为“后进先出”数据结构。这意味着你给数据结构的最后一块数据，当你去从中获取东西时，它将是第一个出来的。所以把它想象成，它被称为栈。就像一叠纸。如果你放下一张纸，然后放另一张在上面，再放另一张在上面，当你去拉最后一张时，去拉最上面那张，它是你放上去的最近的一张。
So if you think about functions, that's the way it works. So if I have function A calls function B calls function C, when I return from C, I want to go back to B. And then when I return from B, I want to go back to A. So I want to go in the reverse order that I just came. And so that's what this return does. So you need somewhere to stick this address of where you came from, the stack, the pointer, the program counter of where you came from.
所以如果你考虑函数，它就是这样工作的。所以如果我有函数A调用函数B调用函数C，当我从C返回时，我想回到B。然后当我从B返回时，我想回到A。所以我想以我刚才来的相反顺序回去。这就是return的作用。所以你需要某个地方来存放这个你从哪里来的地址，栈，指针，你从哪里来的程序计数器。
So you stick it on one of these stack structures, and then you go to your other function. And then when that function finishes or calls another function, but when it finishes and returns, it takes the thing on the stack and goes, jumps to that location. And hopefully if everything worked out right and nothing bad had happened, you'll go back to where you left. So if you were in function A
所以你把它贴在这些栈结构之一上，然后你跳转到你的另一个函数。然后当那个函数完成或调用另一个函数时，但当它完成并返回时，它会从栈上取出那个东西，然后跳转到那个位置。如果一切顺利，没有发生坏事，你就会回到你离开的地方。所以如果你在函数A中，
and you called function B, it did its magic, and then returned, then you'll be back one line past the line where you called function B and function A. So that line plus one. And that's also how things get passed to functions. So you also stick the things, the parameters you're calling the function with,
并且你调用了函数B，它完成了它的魔法，然后返回，那么你就会回到调用函数B的那一行之后的一行，在函数A中。所以那一行加一。这也是参数传递给函数的方式。所以你也把东西，你调用函数时使用的参数，
you stick them on the stack and they get popped back off too. So that's how things get returned as well. So you can get the results of the function as it were. And so that's what the second generation did of BASIC was add these procedures and allow for procedural programming, which comes before object-oriented programming, which is what the third generation attempted to do and that's where you get things like visual basics of VB script which is a way to script Microsoft products maybe others as well I don't I don't know the licensing agreements there and like visual basic net yeah and these kinds of things they try to introduce the notions of object orientedoriented programming to BASIC,
你把它们贴在栈上，它们也会被弹出来。所以这就是返回结果的方式。所以你可以得到函数的结果。这就是第二代BASIC所做的，添加了这些过程并允许过程式编程，这在面向对象编程之前，而第三代试图做的是面向对象，这就是你得到像Visual Basic、VB Script之类的东西的地方，这是一种脚本化微软产品的方式，也许还有其他产品，我不知道那里的许可协议，还有Visual Basic .NET，是的，这些东西，它们试图将面向对象编程的概念引入BASIC，
but we're not really going to talk about those today. This is a nostalgia trip. Yeah, totally. I mean, VB.NET has all sorts of awesome stuff in it, and we'll cover it in another show, but today we're going to just focus on BASIC. So, you know, we both had experiences doing this, and it's one of the things that I consider programming and basic to not have been really programming
但我们今天真的不打算谈论那些。这是一次怀旧之旅。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，VB.NET里面有各种各样的好东西，我们会在另一期节目中介绍它，但今天我们只关注BASIC。所以，你知道，我们都有过这样的经历，这是我考虑编程和BASIC没有真正被视为编程的事情之一。
Oh, it was and it is but I fooled around with various, you know, like I said print Oh, I guess I didn't say this on air So it's like, you know, my first program members like 10 print Patrick rules 20 go to 10 execute right and then Like all the way down and And then you call in your brother, hey, look, man, the computer knows I rule. We would have this arms race. So my cousins were all kind of techies, and most of them were older than me. And so we all had the Commodore 64 manual,
哦，它曾经是，现在也是，但我摆弄过各种，你知道，就像我说的print。哦，我想我没在广播里说过这个。所以就像，你知道，我的第一个程序成员是10 print Patrick rules，20 go to 10，执行，对吧？然后一直往下，然后你叫你兄弟，嘿，看，伙计，电脑知道我说了算。我们会进行这种军备竞赛。所以我的表兄弟们都是技术宅，他们大多数都比我大。所以我们都有Commodore 64手册，
and we used this as sort of a way to see who the alpha programmer was at the time. So someone started with the you know 10 print you know lin rules 20 go to 10 and my cousin was like check it out you know and then i figured out a way to uh like print mine so that it like moved it like kind of bounced left and right on the bottom of the screen because like it just go back to 10 but it put a bunch of spaces in front and so it looked like it was kind of bouncing and then like another one of my cousins found out you could actually write to specific places on the screen like you could say i want like this row and column to have like a letter in it and so she actually
我们用这个作为一种方式来看看当时谁是阿尔法程序员。所以有人从你知道的“10 print lin rules 20 go to 10”开始，我的表弟就像“看看这个”，你知道，然后我想出了一种方法，比如打印我的，让它像在屏幕底部左右弹跳，因为它只是回到10，但在前面放了一堆空格，所以看起来它在弹跳。然后我的另一个表妹发现你可以实际上写入屏幕上的特定位置，比如你可以说我想要这一行和这一列有一个字母，所以她实际上
made her name like bounce like as if it was a little pong ball or something yeah yeah it was super fun so i mean but that kind of encouraging that kind of fun experimentation is really a good way to learn you know it takes it's still another leap to go to programming as a you know getting things done kind of thing um but those those early lessons are valuable and the fact that it's so approachable basic was for kids like it's it's easy to get started in and even though you might move on to other stuff those those early lessons you know about you know oh i want to move but then i want to go back at some time so i need some sort of loop that's counting right you're introducing kind of even if you don't know what you're learning these four loops and then later when
让她的名字像一个小乒乓球一样弹跳，或者其他什么。是的，是的，这超级有趣。所以我的意思是，鼓励这种有趣的实验确实是一种很好的学习方式，你知道，它仍然需要跨越到编程作为一种“完成事情”的领域，但那些早期的课程很有价值，而且它非常平易近人，BASIC是为孩子们准备的，它很容易上手，即使你可能会转向其他东西，那些早期的课程，你知道，关于“哦，我想移动，但我以后想回去，所以我需要某种正在计数的循环”，对吧？你正在引入某种，即使你不知道你在学习什么，这些for循环，然后当你
you learn the proper concepts you can map them back to those early things that you were doing yeah i mean i noticed that like i've taken a lot of different classes and things like just on the web like i'd recently took uh rails for zombies have you seen i have seen that one yeah i took this class and uh and pretty much nothing's now you're a zombie yes brains rails so nothing stuck and like when i went to make a i'd recently made a website in rails i forgot everything like everything i had to go back and relearn and the thing is when you are like when you have a vision in mind whether it's printing your name over and over again or making a website or whatever and you're learning something as part of fulfilling that vision that's when it seems to stick you know it's so much more
学习了正确的概念后，你可以把它们映射回你正在做的那些早期事情上。是的，我的意思是，我注意到，比如我参加过很多不同的课程，比如就在网上，我最近参加了“Rails for Zombies”，你见过吗？我见过那个。是的，我参加了这个课程，而且，几乎什么都没记住，现在你是僵尸了，是的，大脑，Rails。所以什么都没记住，就像当我去做一个我在Rails里的网站时，我忘记了一切，就像一切，我不得不回去重新学习。问题是，当你脑子里有一个愿景时，无论是打印你的名字一遍又一遍，还是制作一个网站，或者其他什么，而你正在学习作为实现该愿景的一部分的东西，那时它似乎就会记住，你知道，它比试图通过课程或类似的东西学习要有效得多，
effective than trying to learn something through a class or something like that and basically gives you the ability it's easy enough where you can start with zero you know like you can start not knowing anything about programming and just have like a vision of oh i want to make like a little dot move around the screen or something i mean you can't have a huge you can't say i want to make you know quake or something i was just thinking quake that's awesome or you know minecraft or something or fortress yes maybe actually that might not be out of that but anyways so um if you if you have the book apparently so yeah i mean but you know if you have a like a simple vision you could start with nothing just start typing in basic and every time you can't do something you look it up on the internet and make get your way through it and you'll be incredibly fulfilling
而且BASIC给了你这种能力，它足够简单，你可以从零开始，你知道，你可以从对编程一无所知开始，只是有一个愿景，比如“哦，我想让一个小点在屏幕上移动”之类的。我的意思是，你不能有一个巨大的，你不能说“我想制作Quake”之类的。我刚才就在想Quake，那太棒了。或者你知道，Minecraft或者Fortress，是的，也许实际上那可能不在那之外，但无论如何，所以，嗯，如果你有书的话，显然。所以是的，我的意思是，但你知道，如果你有一个简单的愿景，你可以从零开始，只需开始输入BASIC，每次你做不到某事时，你就在互联网上查一下，设法完成它，你会感到非常充实，
learning experience so I mean we in some ways I guess as programmers you move on from basic but I mean there are a lot of people who get valuable paying jobs you know just writing you know essentially basic style things and that's great and it is amazing that something that was written so long ago kind of still sticks around, even if it's not vitally important, like it once was, you know, it's still with us. Like we all have fond memories of it. There's still, you know, things you can find, we'll talk about later, like on the internet or whatever, you can just find versions of it free that keep being updated. And every version of Windows
学习体验。所以我的意思是，在某些方面，我想作为程序员，你会从BASIC转向其他，但我的意思是，有很多人获得了有价值的薪水工作，你知道，只是编写，你知道，本质上是BASIC风格的东西，这很棒。而且令人惊奇的是，这么久以前写的东西居然还能留存下来，即使它不像曾经那样至关重要，你知道，它仍然伴随着我们。就像我们都有关于它的美好回忆。仍然有，你知道，你可以找到的东西，我们稍后会谈到，比如在互联网上或其他地方，你可以找到免费的、不断更新的版本。而且每个版本的Windows
apparently was shipping with a version of basicASIC. Yeah, totally. Yeah. I mean, there's, so there's VBA, which is Visual Basic for Applications. And it actually started off as just, I guess, BA. But like in earlier, really early versions of Excel and stuff like that. And you would just write BASIC to, you know, manipulate the cells and things like that. And there's people who, as Patrick said, just do this even to this day. Yeah. I mean, so we traditionally go through like strengths and weaknesses. I mean, we things like that. And there's people who, as Patrick said, just do this even to this day. Yeah. I mean, so we traditionally go through, like,
显然都附带了一个版本的BASIC。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，有VBA，也就是Visual Basic for Applications。它实际上最初只是，我想是BA。但在Excel等软件的早期版本中。你只需编写BASIC来，你知道，操作单元格之类的。而且正如帕特里克所说，有些人直到今天还在这样做。是的，我的意思是，所以我们传统上会经历优点和缺点。我的意思是，我们……有些人直到今天还在这样做。是的，我的意思是，所以我们传统上会经历，
strengths and weaknesses. I mean, we can do that. It's a little strange for this one. But it's so, like Jason said, so easy to sit down with essentially a blank line and get something to happen. And that's really rewarding. Yay, I made the computer do something, right? Like, I programmed it.
优点和缺点。我的意思是，我们可以这样做。这对这个来说有点奇怪。但它就像杰森说的，非常容易坐下来，面对一个空白行，让某些事情发生。这真的很有回报。耶，我让电脑做了点什么，对吧？就像，我编程了它。
And that's amazing. And that's in part due to the approachable syntax. I mean, it does read a lot. Like we said, instead of like printf or cout, it's like print, go to, if, right? I mean, these things are somewhat more understandable and closer to what people know already in their, you know, normal way of communicating. Yeah, and something that I just remembered uh when i was in college there's this guy who was going crazy over dark basic dark is that like the vampire basic yeah it's sort of like rails for zombies oh there's a lot in common but so dark basic is um i think it's commercial
这太神奇了。这部分归功于平易近人的语法。我的意思是，它确实读起来很像。就像我们说的，而不是像printf或cout，它是print，go to，if，对吧？我的意思是，这些东西在某种程度上更容易理解，更接近人们在他们正常的交流方式中已经知道的东西。是的，我刚才想起一件事，我在大学时，有个家伙对Dark Basic非常着迷，Dark是那种吸血鬼BASIC吗？是的，它有点像Rails for Zombies。哦，有很多共同点。但Dark Basic是，嗯，我想它是商业的，
uh let me see you you write games in this i i think i do remember this yeah so i actually allow you to do like graphics programming and stuff. Yeah, I'm not sure if it's free or not. But basically it's a way to get access to DirectX, which is Microsoft's, like, rendering library, like, or rendering platform. And so you can write basic programs, but instead of just kind of printing your name and doing cheesy things that we were talking about,
嗯，让我看看，你用这个写游戏，我想我确实记得这个。是的，所以我实际上允许你做图形编程之类的。是的，我不确定它是否免费。但基本上它是一种访问DirectX的方式，这是微软的，比如，渲染库，或者渲染平台。所以你可以编写BASIC程序，但不仅仅是打印你的名字和做我们刚才谈到的那些俗气的事情，
you could actually, like, create, like, little sprites. You could load images and have them like move around and so for people out there like budding game designers and and people want to sort of like write a game really quick but have no experience in programming you should definitely check out a dark base yeah i remember i mean those were the first games i wrote not that i've written many games but you know something like you're talking about but i actually like there was a way to draw to the screen. And so I would learn about, like, erasing the screen and then drawing a little square and making it bounce off the corners and learned about flipping the velocities, right, which I didn't know was a term, but, like, oh, I need to move five pixels to the right.
你实际上可以，比如，创建，比如，小精灵。你可以加载图像并让它们移动，所以对于那些有抱负的游戏设计师和那些想快速写一个游戏但没有编程经验的人来说，你绝对应该看看Dark Basic。是的，我记得，我的意思是，那些是我写的第一批游戏，不是说我写过很多游戏，但你知道，就像你说的那些，但我实际上喜欢，有一种方法可以画到屏幕上。所以我学会了，比如，擦除屏幕，然后画一个小方块，让它从角落弹开，并学会了翻转速度，对吧？我不知道这是一个术语，但，比如，哦，我需要向右移动5个像素。
But when I hit the screen, I need to know where the screen's at, and then I need to make that negative and move plus minus five pixels, right? And, like, learning how, like, that's how that works and figuring it out and that sense of triumph you have and then also I mean like try to make like a little pac-man thing where the mouth would open and close only instead of using which later learn yet they have sprites to do that right like just various animation I would actually draw like a pie circle like with the angle and then the angle would get smaller and bigger right kind of go across and yeah you don't any difference, so you just make do.
但当我碰到屏幕时，我需要知道屏幕在哪里，然后我需要把它变成负数并移动正负5个像素，对吧？而且，比如，学习如何，比如，那是如何工作的，并弄清楚它，那种你拥有的胜利感，而且我的意思是，比如尝试制作一个像吃豆人那样嘴巴会张合的东西，只是不用，后来学到，他们有精灵来做那个，对吧？就像各种动画，我实际上会画一个像饼图那样的圆，带有角度，然后角度会变小变大，对吧？穿过屏幕，是的，你不知道有什么区别，所以你只是凑合着做。
So this is kind of like a little segue here. But I was reading this really interesting article on – I've been doing a lot of drawing lately, as I mentioned a while ago, maybe in an earlier episode. I have one of those Wacom tablets, those USB drawing tablets. And I've been reading a lot of books and papers on drawing as well. And one of the things that I thought was just fascinating, and I didn't believe it until
所以这有点像是一个小插曲。但我正在读这篇非常有趣的文章——我最近一直在做很多绘画，正如我前一阵子提到的，也许在更早的一集里。我有一个Wacom平板电脑，那种USB绘图板。我也一直在读很多关于绘画的书和论文。我觉得非常迷人的一件事，而且我直到
I actually saw examples of it, is if you have two frames, so imagine like you have one frame where Pac-Man's mouth is open and another frame where his mouth is closed, and you just like flip-flop between these two frames, it will look like weird and cheesy and it won't look right but if you have three frames or i guess in this case five frames so you have like mouth open halfway closed closed halfway closed open like if you just add that third frame there's something in your brain where your brain can't remember three frames back and it looks like fluid motion like this sounds crazy but if you just google that or something or maybe i'll post a link on the blog they have examples where they show like a kick
我亲眼看到它的例子之前都不相信，就是如果你有两帧，所以想象一下你有两帧，吃豆人的嘴是张开的，另一帧嘴是闭合的，你只是在两帧之间来回切换，它看起来会很奇怪、很俗气，看起来不对劲。但如果你有三帧，或者我想在这种情况下是五帧，所以你有嘴张开、半闭、闭合、半闭、张开，如果你只是加上第三帧，你的大脑里有一些东西，你的大脑记不住三帧前，它看起来就像流畅的运动，这听起来很疯狂，但如果你只是谷歌一下那个，或者也许我会把链接贴在博客上，他们有例子，他们展示了一个踢腿，
so almost all of the street fighter 2 is like three frames like all the kicks and punches like it feels really fluid but it's just three frames and they take out the middle frame and just it's just dramatic like you look at this and you're like this is garbage i guess it makes sense because you're the guy's standing there not punching and then the arm is all the way out but you don't really know how it got there yeah but if you draw one in the middle like yeah it's just kind of your brain is interesting yeah it's just shocking like three is like the magic number and it's based on some psychological or neuroscientific thing yeah so so weakness is a basic we've been singing the praises of basic yeah so be the bearer of bad news yeah sadly basic is not going to let you make you know quake 3 yeah it's uh well you know maybe dark basic will but of course you're
所以几乎所有的《街头霸王2》都是像三帧那样的，所有的踢腿和出拳，感觉真的很流畅，但它只有三帧，他们去掉了中间那一帧，它就变得戏剧性了，你看着这个，你会觉得这是垃圾。我想这说得通，因为那家伙站在那里没出拳，然后手臂完全伸出去了，但你真的不知道它是怎么到那里的。是的，但如果你在中间画一个，是的，这只是你的大脑很有趣。是的，这太令人震惊了，3就像是魔数，它基于某种心理学或神经科学的东西。是的，所以，BASIC的缺点，我们一直在唱BASIC的赞歌。是的，所以我是那个带来坏消息的人。是的，可悲的是，BASIC不会让你制作，你知道，Quake 3。是的，它，嗯，你知道，也许Dark Basic会，但当然你
leveraging all those c++ libraries but you know basic by itself it's just uh not only because it's interpreted because we've talked about interpreted languages before but specifically basic just kind of the way that it's designed with like no you know stack frames you know stack frames you have to like manually you know manage that yourself and there's a lot of other reasons it'll never be like high-performing the other thing is it doesn't have a lot of the bells and whistles that would make your life easy as a developer. So it doesn't have multi-threading, it doesn't have object-oriented paradigm. So, you know, it's not going to let you make that killer app. You know, at least
正在利用所有那些C++库，但你知道，BASIC本身，它只是，不仅因为它被解释，因为我们之前讨论过解释型语言，但具体来说，BASIC只是它设计的方式，比如没有，你知道，栈帧，你知道，栈帧你必须手动管理，还有很多其他原因，它永远不会像高性能语言那样。另一件事是，它没有很多会让开发者生活变得轻松的附加功能。所以它没有多线程，它没有面向对象范式。所以，你知道，它不会让你制作那个杀手级应用。你知道，至少
it's going to teach you what you need to know to get there. Yeah, it's definitely started uses. Yeah. And then tools, like we said, there are many versions of Free Basic that are around. It's actually really hard to search for basic, as I found out, because basic programming, and then they just talk about introduction to programming. It's like, no, I want basic programming, not simple programming. So it is a little hard to search for.
它会教你到达那里所需要知道的东西。是的，它绝对有它的用途。是的。然后工具，就像我们说的，有很多版本的Free Basic存在。实际上搜索BASIC真的很难，正如我发现的那样，因为BASIC编程，然后他们只是谈论编程入门。就像，不，我想要BASIC编程，而不是简单的编程。所以搜索它有点难。
But you can find information about it. And there are many web-based versions, free interpreters to download, and it's still a great thing to start today. I think if you have kids or you do one day, I think it would be a great way to introduce them to programming. And like I said, this is how my earliest programming was done in BASIC. Yeah. And BASIC is, I don't know if this is still true. It probably is.
但你可以找到关于它的信息。而且有很多基于网络的版本，可以下载的免费解释器，它今天仍然是一个很好的起点。我想如果你有孩子，或者你将来会有，我认为这将是一个向他们介绍编程的好方法。而且就像我说的，这就是我最早的编程是在BASIC中完成的。是的。而且BASIC是，我不知道这是否仍然属实。它可能仍然是。
But it's in all the Texas Instruments calculators. So when you get that fancy scientific calculator in seventh seventh grade or sixth grade wherever they start requiring that um you can program in it you can make games in basic as we both did yeah so we were actually talking about this so getting one when we were in high school i had a ti 83 i think it was but i think even like 82s and i don't remember all the numbers now yeah okay they yeah they had a version of basic and you had to type on the, like, keys weirdly to get the letters. And somehow, like, I guess as crazy as we think it is, people doing the SMS messaging on, like, the 9 or 10.
但它在所有的德州仪器计算器里。所以当你上七年级或六年级，无论他们什么时候开始要求那个时，当你得到那个昂贵的科学计算器时，嗯，你可以在里面编程，你可以在BASIC里制作游戏，就像我们俩做的那样。是的，所以我们实际上在谈论这个，所以当我们上高中的时候，我有一个TI-83，我想是这样，但我认为即使是82，我不记得所有的数字了。是的，好的，它们，它们有一个版本的BASIC，你必须以奇怪的方式在按键上输入才能得到字母。而且不知何故，比如，我想像我们认为的那样疯狂，人们在9或10上做短信。
Yeah, the T9 thing. Oh, man. But people doing the same kind of thing. We were doing that on calculators. And, you know, it started off like, you know, a math class. Our teacher would say, like, oh, you know, you couldn't, like, eventually there was a way to download from the internet, you could download programs and run them.
是的，T9那种东西。哦，天哪。但人们在做同样的事情。我们在计算器上做那个。而且，你知道，它开始就像，你知道，数学课。我们的老师会说，哦，你知道，你不能，比如，最终有一种方法可以从互联网上下载，你可以下载程序并运行它们。
But if you could program something yourself, you could use it for geometry to compute the hypotenuse of a triangle. So we'd code in simple formulas into our calculators. And then eventually, yeah, I wrote, both of us turned out, we wrote a little RPG. It like a little turn-based fighting game where it was generating random numbers and deciding if you would hit the guy or not. And you just like really simple things. But, you know, you learn a lot.
但如果你能自己编写程序，你可以用它来计算几何中三角形的斜边。所以我们会把简单的公式编码到我们的计算器里。然后最终，是的，我写了，我们俩都写了，我们写了一个小RPG。就像一个小的回合制格斗游戏，它生成随机数并决定你是否会击中那个人。你只是，比如，非常简单的事情。但是，你知道，你学到了很多。
Yeah, totally. I mean, the other thing is we had this awesome arms race in our math class. So, for example, we started writing programs to solve a lot of the geometry problems. And then the teacher, she caught on to it. And she was cool with us writing the programs. The problem is that they were getting into the hands of like all the students in the class. And some students like were just using the program. They didn't really know what was going on. They were just putting in the answer. So she decided that she's going to like make you wipe your calculator. But I didn't want my calculator to get wiped
是的，完全正确。我的意思是，另一件事是我们在数学课上进行了这种很棒的军备竞赛。所以，例如，我们开始编写程序来解决很多几何问题。然后老师，她发现了。她对我们编写程序没意见。问题是它们正在落入班里所有学生的手中。有些学生，比如，只是在使用程序。他们真的不知道发生了什么。他们只是输入答案。所以她决定，她要让你清空你的计算器。但我不想让我的计算器被清空。
because I had all these games on it that I was working on. So I wrote a program that looked like the wipe your calculator screen, but when you hit it, it didn't do anything. And then when you're in middle school or high school, you want to be cool, so I started showing it off, and other people started writing it. So then we all had the program. then the teacher found out about the program and so they didn't ended up with this arms race of like could you keep your stuff on the calculator yeah we didn't have that but we did have people who like learned you like she would allow the teacher would
因为我的计算器里存着我正在开发的所有游戏。所以我写了一个程序，看起来像是要清除计算器屏幕，但当你按下它时，它什么也不会做。在初中或高中时，大家都想耍酷，所以我开始炫耀它，其他人也开始编写它。于是我们都有了这个程序。后来老师发现了这个程序，所以他们最终没有陷入那种“你能不能把东西留在计算器上”的军备竞赛，是的，我们没有那种情况，但确实有人学会了，比如她会允许，老师会
allow maybe I don't remember now would allow programs but they wouldn't actually write programs they didn't know how or didn't care to learn. And I wasn't about to get in big trouble or lose my ability to use it, so I wasn't going to share. I guess I'm meaner than you or something. Man, so you ran like a geometry program mafia or something. No, no, no, no. I just wouldn't share it at all because I wanted to be able to use it.
允许，也许吧，我现在记不清了，会允许程序，但他们实际上并不会编写程序，他们不知道怎么写，或者根本不想学。我可不想惹大麻烦或失去使用它的权利，所以我不会分享。我想我可能比你更刻薄什么的。天哪，所以你经营着一个几何程序黑手党之类的东西。不，不，不，不。我只是根本不分享它，因为我想能够使用它。
Oh, you didn't have the circle of trust? No. Like the circle was just you? Yes. There's's a point i was the earliest google plus with only me um and so uh yeah but people would just instead of writing a program they would just write like a cheat sheet in the in the code right so the code could never run it wouldn't work it would just like write out all the formulas and equations and everything yeah the teacher in spanish class is like, wow these kids are using math to solve
哦，你没有信任圈吗？没有。就像这个圈子只有你一个人？是的。这就像是最早的Google Plus，只有我一个人。所以，是的，但人们不会去写程序，他们只是在代码里写小抄，所以代码根本运行不了，它不会起作用，它只会写出所有的公式、方程式等等。是的，西班牙语老师当时就像是，哇，这些孩子在用数学来解决
Spanish. Oh man, that's pretty funny. So this hasn't been an especially serious version of Programming Throwdown, but it's a trip down. We had some heavy episodes and we had Go, which is like heavy systems programming, like you know, coroutines and all that stuff. And we had Java which is like so much stuff in like, you know, coroutines and all that stuff.
西班牙语问题。天哪，那太搞笑了。所以这期Programming Throwdown并不是特别严肃的版本，而是一次怀旧之旅。我们做过一些沉重的剧集，比如Go语言，那是很硬核的系统编程，你知道，协程之类的东西。还有Java，里面有太多的东西，你知道，协程之类的东西。
And we had Java, which is like so much stuff in Java. So we wanted to keep it light this time. Yeah, have some fun stuff every once in a while. Yeah. There are a lot of programming languages out there. So we've got to cover the fun ones sometime, too. Yeah, totally, totally. All right. Well, thanks, everybody, for kind comments and emails and Google Plus replies.
还有Java，Java里有太多的东西。所以我们这次想保持轻松。是的，偶尔也要做些有趣的内容。是的。外面有很多编程语言。所以我们也得找时间介绍一些有趣的语言。是的，完全同意，完全同意。好了，谢谢大家的友好评论、邮件和Google Plus回复。
And we went through a little bit of changing with the servers, which was fun for Jason. Yeah, I thought I could host programming third under my house. So thank you all for DDoSing Jason's house. So yeah, first of all, we have a lot of fans, way more than we thought, which is totally awesome. I'm going to start seeing if I can collect some metrics to find out exactly how many fans we have.
我们经历了一些服务器变更，这对Jason来说很有趣。是的，我以为我可以在家里托管Programming Throwdown。所以谢谢大家对Jason家进行了DDoS攻击。所以，首先，我们有很多粉丝，比我们想象的要多得多，这真是太棒了。我打算开始收集一些指标，看看我们到底有多少粉丝。
We will find you. Just kidding, just kidding. And their houses. No, I'm just kidding. No, but we have tons of fans. We love you guys. It's awesome. Way more fans than we thought.
我们会找到你们的。开个玩笑，开个玩笑。还有他们的家。不，我只是开个玩笑。不，但我们确实有很多粉丝。我们爱你们。这太棒了。粉丝比我们想象的要多得多。
And, yeah, you guys totally DDoSed my house to the point where I couldn't even check my own email. Oh, sad. So we're back on reliable hosting though so this episode uh you should be able to download it at full bandwidth yeah so apologize for any inconveniences anybody had with that but we are back on track totally all right until next time see you guys later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons Pilot. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且，是的，你们确实把我家DDoS到我连自己的邮件都查不了。哦，真惨。不过我们现在回到了可靠的托管服务上，所以这一集，你应该能够以全带宽下载它。是的，对于给大家带来的任何不便表示歉意，但我们已经回到正轨了。完全没问题，好了，下次见，大家再见。片头音乐是Biner Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享许可协议下发布的。Pilot。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。